hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
vor einigen tagen eine werbung angezeigt
bekommen für einen persönlichkeitstest
und in dieser werbeanzeige stand unsere
leser sagen dass der sixteen personelle
tietz test so genau ist dass es fast ein
bisschen unheimlich ist dachte ich mir
wir machen das jetzt auch mal zusammen
es fällt ihnen schwer sich anderen
menschen vorzustellen das ist bei mir
nicht der fall
sie verlieren sich oft so sehr in
gedanken dass sie ihre umgebung
ignorieren und sogar vergessen
sie versuchen ihre mails möglichst
zeitnah zu beantworten und können einen
unordentlichen posteingang nicht
ertragen das stimmt nicht
es fällt ihnen leicht entspannt und
fokussiert zu bleiben selbst wenn sie
unter ein wenig druck stehen das stimmt
auch nicht ich bin voll das opfer
eigentlich in der tat normalerweise
beginnen sie keine gespräche doch das
stimmt ich beginne eigentlich fast immer
die gespräche weil ich keine freunde
habe sie tun selten etwas aus purer
neugier
das stimmt natürlich wirklich sehr
selten was jetzt sind wir schon auf der
zweiten seite des teils angekommen und
hier steht sie fühlen sich anderen
menschen überlegen
für die schon sagen nee ich würde das
mal komplett neutral belassen
organisiert zu sein ist ihnen wichtiger
als anpassungsfähig zu sein das stimmt
leider menschen ziemlich abstoßend die
sind für gewöhnlich hochmotiviert und
voller energie ich würde das sofort
bisschen in die stimmt region packen und
es ist ihnen wichtiger dass niemand
verärgert wird als dass sie eine debatte
gewinnen
sie haben oft das gefühl dass sie sich
gegenüber anderen rechtfertigen müssen
oh mein gott oh ja das gefühl habe ich
immer ihre umgebung daheim und am
arbeitsplatz ist ziemlich ordentlich
oder steht noch ein eigentlich ist es
für euch gerade komplett uninteressant
euch im test anzugucken den ich es mache
allerdings dass ihm ja vielleicht ist ja
doch irgendwie interessant nein nein
nein
ihre reisepläne sind normalerweise gut
durchdacht ja komplett also ich kann
alles von a bis istanbul der mich von 40
stunden sitzt jetzt fehlt ihnen oft
schwer die gefühle von anderen
nachzuempfinden das will ich nur hier
würde ich das machen
ich kann das halt oft nicht richtig
zuordnen sollen medizinball bin ich ein
drittel des sets haben wir schon
geschafft deswegen machen wir direkt
weiter hiermit bei einer diskussion
sollte die wahrheit wichtiger sein als
die wunden punkte anderer das stimmt
sie sorgen sich selten wie sich ihre
taten auf andere auswirken
ich hatte aus neutral lassen das ist
leider was wo ich mir viel zu selten
gedanken drüber machen ihre arbeitsweise
ähnelt eher willkürlichen energie
schüben als eine methodische und
organisierten anlass das stimmt nicht
ich habe schon mal einen richtigen
ansatz
die hälfte an war schon geschafft sie
verlieren sich seltenen tagträumereien
und gedanken
ja es stimmt leider komplett sie finden
sich oft in tagträumereien wieder wenn
sie in der natur und das stimmt leider
auch wenn jemand nicht schnell auf ihre
e mail antwortet machen sie sich sorgen
ob sie etwas falsches gesagt haben wenn
ich bin auch nicht an menschen die ganze
zeit in unserem chat verlauf hängt und
enkel war antwortete mir endlich als
elternteil wäre es ihnen wichtiger dass
ihr kind freundlich wird als intelligent
ich würde so ein bisschen hier in pac
man beides ist eigentlich wichtig bei
freundlichkeit beruht auch oft auf einer
gewissen intelligenz die vorhanden sein
muss versteht wie ich meinen sie
erlauben anderen menschen nicht ihre
taten zu beeinflussen da stimmt doch gar
keinen fall und die letzte frage für
diese seite ihre träume konzentrieren
sich mehr auf die reale welt und deren
ergebnisse er sprachen lernen da die ich
verstehe die frage auch nicht vor dass
es einfach nur trauen einem neuen
arbeitsplatz machen sie schnell bei
gesellschaftlichen aktivitäten mit ja
definitiv also ich wie gesagt ich bin
gesellschaftlicher mensch sie
improvisieren lieber als sorgsam zu
planen das stimmt nicht ich bin denn ich
hatte ihre emotionen steuern sie mehr
als dass sie diese steuern das verstehe
ich wieder nicht so richtig
sie gehen gern zur gesellschaftlichen
veranstaltungen bei denen man sich
verkleidet oder rollenspiele stattfinden
ich
und karneval ja eigentlich so was raus
also nein und die letzte frage auf
dieser seite ist sie improvisieren
lieber als zeit damit zu verbringen
einen detaillierten plan auszuarbeiten
das gefühl jede zweite frage
das stimmt nicht wie gesagt ich bin ein
planungs mensch ich bin der boss sie
sind eine relativ ruhige und
zurückhaltende person das würde ich eher
ein bisschen hierhin packen wenn sie ein
unternehmen hätten würde es ihnen
schwerfallen loyale mitarbeiter zu
entlassen die allerdings geringe
leistung bringen das stimmt dass das
stimmt ich find loyalität ist somit das
allerwichtigste egal ob privat oder
arbeit die machen sich oft gedanken über
den grund der menschlichen existenz nein
habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie gemacht
logik ist normalerweise wichtiger als
ein herz und bauchgefühl wenn wichtige
entscheidungen anstehen das stimmt und
ihnen ist es wichtiger flexibel zu
bleiben als aufgabenlisten zu haben bzw
abzuarbeiten das stimmt nicht
ich bin eigentlich echtes opfer merklich
gerade die letzte frage auf dieser seite
ist wenn ihr freund beziehungsweise ihre
freundin über etwas traurig ist dann
bieten sie wahrscheinlich eher
emotionale unterstützung als das die
möglichkeiten zur problemlösung vorstand
das stimmt nicht
[Musik]
wenn ein freund oder eine freundin von
mir traurig ist weiß ich dass sich die
traurige person halt wahrscheinlich eher
über etwas emotionales freuen würde also
emotionale anteilnahme oder ein gespräch
oder irgendwie so war es allerdings bin
ich eher der ansicht dass es auf dauer
mehr sinn macht konstruktiv an die sache
ranzugehen und eine problemlösung zu
entwickeln das hört sich jetzt so so
kalt und und kühl und strategisch
taktisch an
aber es macht wirklich sinn ich bin dann
einfach der ansicht und diese
philosophie von mir mehr oder weniger
hab ich auch schon öfters in unserem
podcast er vor dem ministerrat eine neue
episode reingegangen ist also schon
gärten in der video beschreibung vor ich
bin einfach der ansicht wenn man wegen
etwas traurig ist was man ändern kann
dann sollte man es ändern und dann lohnt
es sich eine problemlösung zu entwickeln
und konkret daran zu arbeiten so dass
man nicht mehr traurig ist wenn man
allerdings wegen etwas traurig ist dass
man nicht ändern kann dann sollte man
emotional an die ganze sache rangehen
das hört sich jetzt so sehr strategisch
gedacht an aber ich glaube ihr versteht
was ich meine und das ist halt so ein
bisschen meine herangehensweise bei
sowas am allerdings machen wir hier mit
weiter sie fühlen sich selten unsicher
das würde ich sagen stimmt so ein
bisschen wir haben keine probleme damit
einen persönlichen zeitplan festzulegen
und sich daran zu halten
es hallt das ding ich entwickelt sehr
häufig pläne allerdings ist das dran
halten hätte immer so ein bisschen
schwierig von daher würde ich das ja
auch einfach neutral beantworten nächste
frage ist bzw aussage recht zu haben ist
bei der teamarbeit wichtiger als
kooperativ zu sein ich will
auch neutral belassen wenn du mit fünf
leute in der gruppe bist und alle fünf
leute haben eine falsche lösung man
selbst hat die richtige lösung dann
bringt das nichts für die teamarbeit
wenn man kooperativ ist ich bin ein sehr
faktenbasierte menschen sie sind der
ansicht dass alle meinungen respektiert
werden sollten und zwar unabhängig davon
ob diese von fakten gestützt werden oder
nicht
nein auf gar keinen fall aktuellstes
beispiel ist leer und lockt mit seiner
komischen ja das glaube ich dir damit
bekommen also auf gar keinen fall und
die letzten aussagen sind sie haben mehr
energie nachdem sie zeit mit einer
gruppe von leuten verbracht haben
auf gar keinen fall danach habe ich gar
keine energie mehr die letzte aussage
ist sie verlegen regelmäßig ihre sachen
das ist neutral würde ich sagen
also wenn ich etwas verschieben was auf
meiner to-do-liste steht dann rückt was
anderes rein
ich würde schon sagen dass ich sehr
produktiv bin allerdings pläne halt
leider oft bahn haufen werfe die stufen
sich selbst als emotional sehr stabil
ein
das dachte ich als allerdings letztes
jahr meine ganzen großeltern gestorben
sind ist mir aufgefallen dass es
überhaupt nicht der fall ist ihr kopf
ist stets voller unerforschter ideen und
pläne das würde ich auch neutral halten
und die nächste aussage ist sie würden
sich selbst nicht als träumer
beziehungsweise träumerin bezeichnen
ich würde ich tatsächlich auch neutral
beantworten
es fällt ihnen gewöhnlich schwer sich zu
entspannen wenn sie vor vielen menschen
sprechen das stimmt ich weiß noch als
ich meine millionen play button bei den
bei den video days vor 10.000 leuten im
bereich bekommen habe und danach musste
ich erst mal drei tonnen aus meiner
unterhose rauskramen hobby nun
allerdings auch schon zur letzten seite
dieses persönlichkeitstests und zwar in
einem vollen raum bleiben sie näher an
der wand und meiden die raummitte ist
unterschiedlich kommt immer darauf an
mit welchen leuten nicht da bin von
deswegen da denn sie neigen dazu dinge
aufzuschieben bis nicht mehr genug zeit
bleibt um alles zu erledigen das stimmt
nicht
sie sind sehr nervös und stressigen
situationen
würde ich schon so ein bisschen er hier
beantworten
sie glauben dass es lohnenswert ist von
anderen gemocht zu werden als
einflussreich zu sein
nun will ich neutral lassen
sie haben sich schon immer für
unkonventionelle und mehrdeutige dinge
interessiert zum beispiel was bücher
kunst oder filme angeht stimmt nicht
kommen wir jetzt auch schon zur letzten
frage dieses tests und zwar in
gesellschaftlichen situation ergreifen
sie oft die initiative 100 prozent hier
sehen wir jetzt die auswertung eines
persönlichkeitstests und zwar bin ich
beim verstand sonne mitte aus
extrovertiert und introvertiert meine
energie ist er realistisch hinsichtlich
der natur bin ich eher logik fokussiert
das hätte ich ja schon vorher sagen
können bei den taktiken bin ich eher
planen und bei meiner identität bin ich
erst stürmisch wie es stimmt die farben
aber wenn wir allerdings jetzt ein
bisschen runter scrollen sehen wir schon
dass meine persönlichkeit hier
beschrieben wird und zwar exekutivkräfte
repräsentieren tradition und ordnung
durch ihre überzeugung von dem was
richtig und was falsch ist was sozial
verträglich und das verwerflich ist
stärken sie die zusammenhalt von
familien und gemeinschaften menschen mit
dem persönlichkeitstyp der exekutiv
kraft verinnerlichen die werte von
ehrlichkeit engagement und respekt sie
sind gerne bereit auf schwierigen wegen
voranzugehen und werden für ihre guten
ratschläge und führungsqualität ich bin
gerne auf dem weg von der toilette bis
hierhin zwei mal ausgerutscht und die
sagen mir ich habe führungsqualitäten
exekutivkräfte sind in demokratischen
gesellschaften sehr gefragte machen
nicht weniger als elf prozent der
bevölkerung aus es ist kein wunder dass
viele der bekanntesten politiker und
wirtschaftsführer diesem
persönlichkeitstyp zuordnen zuzuordnen
sind sollten sich angela merkel
exekutivkräfte sind ein prototyp des
musterbürger sie helfen ihren nachbarn
verteidigen gesetz und ordnung und
mobilisieren ihre mitmenschen zur
teilnahme an gesellschaftlichen
organisation und strukturen
ja wir sehen uns dann in drei jahren
wenn ich bundeskanzler habe
an der stelle ich das heute wieder
allerdings auch bei ihnen meine lieben
freunde wie bereits gesagt habe ich
einfach eine werbung gesehen mit diesem
persönlichkeit und habe gedacht ich
mache den mal für mich was interessant
vielleicht was für euch ja auch
interessant und hat mich ein bisschen
besser kennengelernt jetzt befinden uns
allerdings auch im auto meine lieben
freunde die obersten smiley wenn ihr da
noch nicht drauf geklickt habe dann
könnt ihr da mal drauf klicken passiert
was supertolles können ihm einen kanal
abonnieren und verpasst keine videos
mehr
und hier ist so ein anderes video was
ihr vielleicht verpasst habt also klick
darauf wenn ihm nichts zu tun hat und
ich glaube keiner hat etwas zu tun